en un mot oui il y a c'est lire mais bon
je vais suivre les conseils de thibault
et faire preuve d'un peu de charité
interprétative bien entendu quand on
pense à savoir lire on pense aussi à
comprendre ce qu'on dit est ce qu'il
n'ya comprend la sémantique de ce
qu'elle lit dans quelle mesure peut-on
dire qu'une ia exposé un livre comprend
ce qu'elles y trouvent en novembre 2010
est une collaboration entre facebook
l'université du mans et l'université
pierre et marie curie a produit une ia
et ses tirs semblent montrer une
étonnante maîtrise de la sémantique des
mots pour comprendre cela je vais vous
décrire l'expérience qui a été réalisé
en partant de rien il y à a commencé à
lire énormément de textes en anglais et
à partir de ce cas lisez en anglais elle
a cherché à un ferrer le sens des mots
anglais
plus précisément elle a construit une
interprétation sémantique des mots
qu'elle lisait ce qui revient à
construire une fonction qui prend des
données brutes
ici des mots et en extrait une
représentation sémantique comme on l'a
vu la dernière fois ça correspond à une
fonction qui transforme un espace de
très grande dimension en un espace de
dimensions raisonnables
typiquement en passant d'une dimension
des est égal à 1 million à une dimension
c'est égal 300 bref après avoir lu
énormément en anglais lille s'est mise à
trouver une interprétation sémantique de
ce qu'elle disait mais on peut se
demander si cette interprétation
sémantique est bonne et si elle
correspond à notre interprétation
sémantique berra je vais laisser cette
question en suspens pour aujourd'hui
convenons-en à l'expérience client en
question ensuite fait la même chose pour
d'autres langues comme le français
elle s'est mise à à lire énormément de
textes en français mais je précise que
ces textes en français n'était
absolument pas des traductions des
textes en anglais
elle a juste lui du français et comme
pour l'anglais l'ira s'est mise à
construire une représentation sémantique
des mots de la langue française
à partir de ce qu'elle disait en france
elle donc j'ai capitulé on a des textes
en anglais et des sémantique de
l'anglais ainsi que des textes en
français et des ses antiques du français
serait ce possible d'exploiter la
sémantique pour créer ainsi un canal de
traduction
intuitivement c'est comme ça qu'il
faudra effectuer des traductions de
l'anglais au français il faudrait lire
le texte en anglais en inférer le sens
puis exprimer ce sens en français et
intuitivement la clé de cette approche
c'est le fait que la sémantique est
quelque chose d indépendants du langage
dans lequel elle est exprimée
j'ai presque envie de dire que si on
parvient déterminé quelque chose qui est
indépendant de toute langue alors ce
sera la sémantique
non vous pouvez deviner où je veux en
venir
les cinq chercheurs ont montré que la
sémantique de l'anglais la sémantique du
français était en fait deux espaces
quasi isomorphe dans le sens où on peut
tourner l'espace de sémantique anglais
pour le faire quasiment coïncidé avec
l'espace de sémantique français voilà
qui permit aux cinq chercheurs de créer
un canal qui va des textes en anglais à
la sémantique anglaise à la sémantique
française au texte français
ce canal permis aux cinq chercheurs
d'effectuer des traductions de l'anglais
au français
devinez quoi oui cette approche surpasse
toutes les autres approches de
traduction mot-à-mot y compris celles où
fournissait aux ja ne liste de
traduction botha mots et en particulier
je pense que cette expérience montre que
en un certain sens les ja sont capables
d'inférer du sens de ce qu'elle lise
alors ça veut pas dire qu'elles ont
atteint un niveau humain en lecture je
pense qu'un élève de ce1 est encore
meilleur que les ya notamment parce que
les ja ont du mal à un ferrer le sens
d'une phrase d'un paragraphe mais la
recherche onia avance et al avance très
vite je ne serais pas surpris si dans
les années à venir
les ja atteignent un niveau collège ou
lycée en lecture voire plus alors bien
sûr il ya plein de détails que j'ai
sauté dans ses explications il y aurait
énormément plus à dire notamment parce
que ça repose sur des réseaux de
neurones et des modèles adverse are you
on y reviendra
mais pour la 2e partie de cet épisode
j'aimerais m'arrêter sur l'opération que
je trouve être la plus spectaculaire
dans cette expérience à savoir la
construction de la sémantique
comment est ce possible pour lisions des
textes en anglais on puisse donner un
sens à l'anglais qu'est ce qui fait que
les mots ont un sens et qu'est-ce qui
fait le sens des mots et bien
l'hypothèse fondamentale de
l'apprentissage de la sémantique des
mots
est le postulat du linguiste john firme
qui disait vous connaîtrez un mot par la
compagnie qu'il conserve
autrement dit ce n'est pas le mot en lui
même qui lui donne son sens ce qui donne
un sens au mot l ensemble des phrases où
il apparaît le sens des mots est donné
par les contextes où ils sont utilisés
et ça peut vous paraître bizarre mais si
vous avez bien suivi ma série sur
l'infini c'est quelque chose dont on a
déjà parlé
ce qui fait qu un objet mathématique est
intéressant ce n'est pas l'objet en
lui-même mais ses relations aux autres
objets l'ensemble des relations entre
les objets formation est une structure
et c'est finalement les propriétés de
cette structure qui importe plus que le
nom qu'on donne aux objets de cette
structure en particulier deux structures
parleront finalement de la même chose si
elles sont idiots morts bref tout ça
pour dire que le sens d'un mot c'est
avant tout son contexte d'utilisation et
ce contexte est tout simplement
l'ensemble des mots qui l'accompagnent
c'est ce principe que les informaticiens
ont cherché à à formaliser particulier
en 2013
quatre chercheurs de google nikolov
chaîne corrado et dean ont réussi une
percée dans ce domaine
à l'aide d'un réseau de neurones capable
d'exploiter les relations d'un mot homos
qui l'entourent pour créer une
représentation sémantique des mots sur
réseaux de neurones et appelé world
check
il est devenu un ustensile
incontournable dans l'analyse
automatisée des textes de façon
spectaculaire
quand deux mots sont sémantiquement
proches comme chats et chiens world
check les transforment en des vecteurs
sémantique également proche au sens où
l'angle entre les deux vecteurs est
petit la proximité des représentations
sémantique des mots correspond bel et
bien à une proximité sémantique au sens
intuitif de la sémantique mais ce n'est
pas sur le réseau de neurones qui a
réussi cette prouesse que j'aimerais
m'arrêter
ce dont j'aimerais vraiment vous parler
c'est d'une publication de 2014 de marc
levy et yoav kohlberg le tour de force
de cette publication fut de montrer que
world check est en fait une sorte de svd
l'algorithme quand un appareil dans
l'épisode précédent et qui a servi à
prédire si les utilisateurs de netflix
allaient aimer tel ou tel film oui parce
que souvenez vous svd consistait à
exploiter des relations entre les films
et les utilisateurs comme les notes
d'utilisateurs pour des films
pour créer un espace de sémantique film
utilisateurs et on avait vu que cet
espace représente très bien des
relations entre les films typiquement
les films violents seront des vecteurs
semblables dans l'espace de sémantique
film utilisateurs de la même façon world
studec consiste finalement à un ferrer
la sémantique des mots à partir des
fréquences auxquelles ce mot est utilisé
dans tel ou tel contexte
ces relations entre les mots et les
contextes permettent alors de créer un
espace de sémantique beaux textes et
bien c'est cet espace de sémantique mot
contexte que j'ai tout simplement appelé
espace de sémantique des langues
anglaise et française ces espaces de
sémantique sont tellement bien foutu
qu'ils permettent la traduction d'une
langue à l'autre en passant par le
calcul du sens des mots
alors il ya pas mal de subtilité
concernant watts tu veilles notamment
dans la manière dont les relations entre
les mots et les contextes sont
comptabilisés en particulier certains
mots sont très fréquents et d'autres
sont peu fréquents du coup il faut un
peu lisse et les fréquences des mots
typiquement avec une fonction
logarithmique et puis un autre problème
c'est que les mots peu fréquents sont
cohérents avec plusieurs contextes mais
il ya de bonnes chances qu'il n'y ait
aucun exemple de l'apparition de ces
mots dans ces contextes dans les textes
qu'à lui il ya du coup il faut faire
gaffe à ne pas pénaliser l'absence de
ces exemples nous assez les détails près
avec quelques autres watch tu veux
vraiment une sorte de svd bref ce que je
trouve fascinant dans toute cette
histoire c'est peut-être avant tout les
conséquences épistémologique de ses
travaux sur la sémantique désir en
particulier world check suggère qu'il
est tout à fait possible d'insérer le
sens des textes simplement en lisant des
textes
voilà qui peut paraître très bizarre
intuitivement on a envie de dire que le
sens des mots qu'on lit est relié à
toutes sortes de données sensorielles
notamment et qu'on ne peut pas vraiment
comprendre le sens de ces mots ne
faisant que lire des livres
par exemple si je vous dis que je vois
que cette robe est bleu et noir n'ont
ville de dire qu'une ya ne pourrait
jamais ressentir cette sensation de bleu
et noir
en tout cas par ne faisant que lire des
textes alors on pourra rétorquer cugnac
il y eut ipdia y verra aussi des images
et pourra du coup ressentir les couleurs
mais si je prends maintenant l'exemple
d'une sensation comme
peur ou la joie là on a vraiment envie
de dire qu'il s'agit de sémantique
qu'unia ne pourra jamais vraiment
ressentir en tout cas pas en ne faisant
que lire des textes et bien je n'en
serais pas si sûr au final la peur ce
n'est qu'une forme d'activation de
certains neurones de nos cerveaux et je
serai du genre à parier qu'une ia qu'il
y ait suffisamment de textes notamment
des romans à suspense où l'auteur décrit
la peur des personnages par exemple
cette ia pourrait bel et bien finir par
créer une sémantique de la peur dont la
relation au contexte de la peur et
isomorphe à ce qu'il se passe dans nos
cerveaux au quelqu'un les sensations de
peur chelia pourrait être physiquement
indiscernable des sensations de peur
chez un humain
plus généralement on parle beaucoup de
la nécessité de big data pour les ir
pour comprendre le monde qui nous
entoure
sauf que des données massives et publics
de grande qualité sont déjà disponibles
par exemple sur wikipédia ou sur youtube
et unia qui sait lire et écouter mais
genre vraiment bien lire eh bien écoutez
c'est à dire on se cherchant constamment
à un ferrer un maximum de sémantique de
ce qu'elle lit si cette ia ne cessait
pas de lire et relire wikipedia d'
écouter réécouter youtube
je parierais centre au flipper que cette
ia atteindrait un niveau de
compréhension du monde bien supérieure à
celle de n'importe quel humain elle
comprendrait le sarcasme et l'humour
elle distinguerez l'effet que mieux et
les trolls et elle saurait mieux que
vous comment améliorer sa propre
intelligence et vous qu'en pensez vous
unia qu'ils ne partiraient de rien si ce
n'est un excellent algorithmes de
machine learning et j'entends par là un
truc bien plus performant que tout ce
qu'on fait aujourd'hui plus parisien
notamment une telle ya qui n'auraient
accès qu'à wikipedia peut-elle devenir
en tout point supérieure à l'homme avant
de revenir à vos commentaires une petite
annonce je ferai un youtube live si tout
se passe bien
mercredi donc ce mercredi là le 2 mai à
16 heures donc c'est de vous brancher en
fait ce sera une conférence que je vais
donner ici à le pfl qui sera se mirent
informel et qui soit aussi soumis
scientifique voire carrément hostiles
aux scientifiques
c'est un petit peu pour tester le
matériel et le youtube blague puisque
thibaut giraud viendra monsieur fille
viendra à le pfl donné une conférence si
on essaie d'organiser un youtube live
également pour ça donc on est un petit
peu le matériel mais du coup c'est aussi
l'occasion pour moi de donner une
conférence
et en l'occurrence ça va je vais parler
d'un truc que je trouve absolument
fondamental même si ça se traite
difficilement avec la méthode
scientifique notamment puisque je vais
parler de philosophie on va dire sur la
différence entre à apprendre et
comprendre qui est je pense une
distinction extrêmement importante à
faire tant d'un point de vue pédagogique
que au niveau de la recherche notamment
en ce moment avec les intelligences
artificielles qu'on ne comprend pas on
peut se demander comment penser ces
intelligences artificielles et qu'est ce
que pourrait vouloir dire que comprendre
le fonctionnement des intelligences
artificielles et pour répondre à toutes
ces questions notamment je vais avoir un
angle très algorithmique pouvoir
vraiment utilisé la théorie de
l'informatique et de l'algorithmique
pour essayer d'avoir une réponse à cette
question et je suis prêt à parier que la
vie que je vais donner va être
complètement différent de tout ce que
vous avez entendu à ce sujet l'anr fois
on avait parlé d'état cp2 svd vous avez
une fois qu'ils avaient utilisé par les
équipes qui vont chercher à résoudre le
prix netflix pour prédire les notes que
des utilisateurs donnera à des films
notamment et pour y arriver il fallait
un terme en place et les films les
utilisateurs dans un espace de
sémantique film utilisateurs et a priori
dans secret présenté un art fois chaque
note pour chaque film correspondait à
quelque chose qui avait le même poids
que n'importe quel autre note importe
quel autre film pour placer les gens
dans cet espace d'à sémantique et joseph
me sente nous demande aussi justement
une note pour un film qui est déjà très
populaire ne pourrait pas avoir du coup
moins d'influx ans que d'autres notes
données par exemple à des films
moins connue il ya deux pas dans cette
question est la partie qui je pense est
pas la question mais j'ai quand même
répondre qui est ce que ces influences
beaucoup la position du film par exemple
titanic qui ont été notés pas énormément
de gens bien a priori le problème c'est
que le point films comme titanic eu
beaucoup trop de notes par rapport à
l'espace des sémantique qui est vision
de dimension on va dire sans et du coup
s'il y a un million de notes
il ya en fait les contraintes sont
incompatibles en fait les hyper plan ou
est-ce qu'il voulut doit être compatible
et à ce moment là on va essayer de
trouver une position qui est autant
compatible que possible avec les
différentes notes données par
différentes personnes et du coup donc ça
revient reprennent d'optimisation et
qu'il faut résoudre mais du coup à ce
moment là chaque note d'un utilisateur
va avoir une influence qui va être assez
limité sur la position in fine et du
film titanic dans l'espace des
sémantique film utilisateurs donc l'
influence pour les films populaires et
très faible au plus on peut s'y attendre
c'est par être pas très surprenant en
revanche la question plus intéressant de
savoir est ce que pour un utilisateur et
fait qu'ils aient noté le titanic par
exemple est ce que c est raisonnable dû
donner la même importance qu une note
qu'il a donnée à des films peu connus
qui finalement exprime quelque chose de
plus particulier finalement par rapport
à la personne en question qu'a priori il
dirait que svt prend pas tellement
ceux-ci on compte 1 dans les deux cas à
chaque note ça correspond à un hyper
plan intersections des hyper plan et
c'est peut-être un peu dommage ce qu'on
pourrait peut-être vouloir dire c'est
que mon ip repent avec une incertitude
sur nous on est par rapport à cette
hyper plan et finalement ça c'est
exactement le problème qui se pose
lorsqu'on essaie de faire svd aux
problèmes de
la sémantique entre les mots et les
contextes puisqu'il ya des mots qui vont
toujours toujours toujours apparaître et
des mots qui vont peut apparaître et on
veut d'une certaine manière donner plus
d'importance à certaines apparitions de
certains mots dans certains contextes
c'est quelque chose qui est rouée faire
c'est automatiquement par
world culek notamment bref tout ça pour
dire qu'en fait elle s est un peu un
paradigme truc qui marche très très bien
mathématiquement donc c'est pour ça
qu'on ne présente plus et c'est
généralement parce qu'il utilise est
directement et puis il ya plein de
bidouillages que l'on peut faire de svd
pour soi l'adapter au problème soit
faire en sorte que ça marche mieux
notamment svd très gourmand au temps de
calcul en tout cas potentiellement très
gourmande en temps de calcul notamment
parce que benjamin gates mais qui est
pas forcément adapté pour les matrices
rappelle creuse c'est à dire une matrice
bien peu de notes d'utilisateurs pour un
film bonne école je veux dire en général
si on prend un film réutilisateurs
l'utilisateur a pas vu ce film du coup
je peux pas lui donner de notes donc
dans le cas de matrix creusant fait svd
assez gourmande en temps de calcul et
c'est pour ça que des solutions comme
world to make qui sont rapidement
beaucoup plus préférable et qu'on
utilise souvent des algorithmes et qui
sont plus pas directement ceux de la dja
binaire mais plus des algorithmes comme
la descente de gradient stochastique
dont on reparlera noms de futurs
épisodes
valérian réagit un truc que j'avais dit
dans la vidéo que j'ai dit que je n'ai
pas comparé les pommes et brahimi de
sacs les pommes et les bananes ça je
pense que si on veut vraiment dire s'il
faut pas comparer disons des bananes
avec des raisins plus compliqué et ça
c'est finalement parce que un raisin on
sent intuitivement que ce n'est pas
vraiment comparable à une banane
parce que en termes de taille ou des
apports nutritifs tout ce que vous
voulez et façon plus générale en fait ce
problème notamment ce que des unités
très différente donc si j'avais donné
aussi l'exemple du nombre d'années
d'existence d'une chaîne youtube qui se
compte tours en 1 2 3 4 5 6 j'aimais pas
plus que disent que rarement plus que 10
puisque 10 mai avant puisque vent on va
dire très clairement puisque youtube
si je m'abuse qui nous barrer au nombre
de vue d'une chaîne qui peut se compter
en millions voire en milliards pour est
très conscient que si on fait une assez
paix sur ce genre de données
eh ben on voit que les variations selon
la dimension nombre de vues seront
beaucoup plus grande puisque elles
varieront les variations seront de
l'ordre du milliard alors que si je
regarde les variations selon nombre
d'années n'a quasiment pas du coup
automatiquement la cpval ignorer la
donner sur une ombre d'année c'est pas
parce que les nombres d'années n'est pas
une variable pertinente c'est parce que
l'échelle qu'on a choisi en nombre
d'années fait que les variations sur
cette échelle sont de l'ordre de 1,2
enfin 5 quelque chose comme ça si on
avait repris cette même dimension on
avait changé l'unité dont était passé en
seconde par exemple en nanosecondes en
temps de planck d'existence tout de
suite ça fait désirer complètement
différente et la cp aurait complètement
changé à son interprétation et se serait
mise complètement ignoré les variations
selon le nombre de vues peuvent de façon
plus générale des conclusions de la cpd
pente très fortement des unités qui sont
choisis et avec certaines unités de la
cp peut être amené à ignorer les
variations qui en fait sont extrêmement
pertinente pour d'autres applications en
particulier si je reprends le cas dans
mon assiette
en fait il est possible que pour
certaines analyses ils soient vraiment
primordial de prendre en compte les
variations selon cette direction et
auquel cas en fait la cp
manquerait vraiment quelque chose y
compris lorsque les unités de mesure
dans les différentes dimensions sont les
mêmes a cp a ses limites
ça veut dire qu'il faut jamais utiliser
mais faut savoir aussi que la cpa
certaines limites et qu'il ne va pas
être adapté dans certains cas ceci étant
dit dans d'autres cas ça marche vraiment
du tonnerre notamment dans le cas de son
application pour svd pour résoudre le
prix netflix
enfin je vais me permettre de donner
encore un peu plus de détails sur les
fonctionnements de la cp et de sauver
des fêtes dans les deux cas ces deux
algorithmes repose énormément sur la
notion d' orthogonale it et
contrairement à la régression linéaire
et la notion monde orthogonale it et en
particulier pour ses différentes
matrices à cette propriété assez
fondamental que si vous prenez une
matrice qui a certaines propriétés
notamment si elle est symétrique
donc si on trouve des directions qui
sont bien en un certain sens à ce qu'ils
sont directement dans le plus grand des
relations ils sont en particulier des
vecteurs propre une certaine maîtrise on
appellerait de convergence alors en gros
tout ce qui se passe de façon
orthogonale qui est perpendiculaire à
cette direction va rester de certains
venir indépendant de cette direction et
donc les variations vraiment d'un nuage
de points dans une direction orthogonale
dans toutes les directions orthogonale à
sa direction de variation principal
toutes ces directions lattois assez
indépendante ans à 60 ans fait son non
corrélées aux variations dans l'autre
sens et c'est un peu la clé de s&p est
celui qui est la clé en fait une des
théories fondamentales qui est sur
lesquels reposera 6 p à savoir le fait
que tout motrices symétrique et au
diagonal is able embase orthonormé si
vous prenez un vecteur propre d'une
matrice symétrique en effet vous pouvez
prendre n'importe quels vecteurs
orthogonale à ce lecteur propre l'image
de sept de ses lecteurs qui orthogonale
aux vecteurs propre par la matrice
symétrique
bon bah il va il va tourner quelque part
mais cette image sera encore orthogonale
aux vecteurs propre et ses lecteurs
propre là il ya un changé entre que sa
direction ayant changé par la matrice
ses métriques par des filles sont des
vecteurs propres et c'est ça qui fait
que tout matrice symétrique et
diabolisent abl
blazer très normé et notre bonne chose
par rapport à la cbc que la matrice de
covariance rs quand elle se mit défini
positive mais bon je pas disserter plus
encore sur tout ça mais cette propriété
de matrix matrix me définis positive
c'est un truc qui apparaît énormément
notamment en optimisation puisque c'est
lié à son comble c'est qu'ils ont du
coup facile à résoudre
bref il y aurait énormément plus à dire
tout ça pour vous dire que la diabline
hier que vous apprenez ans bakulin au
bac + 2
c'est un truc qui en fait fondamental en
machine en ligne et j'espère que vous
avez aimé cet épisode il reste en fait
deux épisodes encore sur la sémantique
la prochaine fois on va creuser un petit
peu cette histoire de sémantique des
mots et pas que des mots d'ailleurs
aussi la sémantique des images et on va
voir que notamment on peut faire de
l'arithmétique sur les cinématiques ce
qui fait un truc assez mind boeing
notamment les chercheurs qui ont
découvert ça
grard par qui on sent la surprise qu'ils
ont ressentie au moment de découvrir que
il avait réussi à faire ça alors que
c'était pas du tout objectif originale
de leurs articles si vous avez aimé cet
épisode penser à le lac et à le
commenter à le partager pensez à vous
abonner pour ne pas manquer les futurs
épisodes merci aux ti peur pour leurs
dons et j'espère que vous serez là la
prochaine fois et terme en 2011 et un
mec s'appelle tenenbaum
yahoo qui a publié un article où il
présente trois images d'un truc qu'il
appelle tu fais ça veut rien dire les
images représentent rien de réel il dit
bon bah ça c'est un tu face à saintes
uva et ça c'est un tu fais ensuite il
montre 39 image et il nous demande de
trouver les tu vas tu vas sont pas les
mêmes c'est des objets c'est comme des
animaux que des plantes est ce qu'il
faut c'est que on est tous d'accord dit
ce texte
sinon il lui a dit ils donnent tous les
fraudeurs ce trio magique